Some people may long to wipe the boss out of their lives in a heartbeat...
...as Jonah Hill did as Donnie Azoff in "The Wolf of Wall Street."
He literally phones in his resignation.
Hey Paulie, what's up?
No, everything's fine.
Hey listen, I quit!
Don't come looking for a reference from me.
Okay, I won't.
In most real-life situations, however, making such an outburst doesn't pay off.
One of the best known illustrations is Tom Cruise's departure scene...
...in the 1996 film "Jerry Maguire."
If anybody else wants to come with me,...
...this moment will be the moment of something real and fun...
...and inspiring in this godforsaken business, and we will do it together.
Who's coming with me?
After the spectacle is over, bosses and former colleagues...
...can hurt your reputation through gossip or bad references.
The bottom line?
Leave your ex-employer with nothing to use against you.
Make goodwill the goal and leave drama to the movies.